today's topic
hey guys i just want to take this chance
to um
you know come out today i've been very
confused about how i identify
i've seen a lot of other people online
that have come out and been very brave
about it and shared their story about
how they identify
their gender their pronouns etc so you
know i've taken courage from these
incredibly brave um people and it is
pride month at the moment so
you know i thought this was the best
time to do it um you know what this is
like
this man just slipped into the back of
the parade and tried to bring his cause
with him equal rights
and the car passes by the second one
comes in they're like trains rights
and then the third kind of comes it's
like i want to touch kids what
huh what do you say but the car's
already passing
so i am going to come out today and say
that i've been transitioning i've been
very unhappy with who i am deep down um
for the last eight years and i've
you know i've had like 18 plastic
surgeries now and i've just had a face
lift um
a brow lifted temple lift an eye surgery
a canthoplasty um
and my teeth as well um just these are
just part of my transition
for the first time in my life i feel
beautiful you know i'm looking in the
mirror and i love the way i look and
feel happy and i hope people can respect
my decision it's a very tough decision
to come out this way
and my pronouns are they then korean
jimin she said his pronoun is korean
that that's not a pronoun it's like a
girl's i just want to talk to you about
something
that's been on my mind for uh a long
time and
so for all this time like i've had uh a
cup
and i've done surgery and now i'm like a
d so my pronouns
are he she we big boobs how to pronounce
it
sounds like a good korean barbecue
[Music]
[Applause]
fire i'm not even gonna frustrate you
because i know a lot of people don't
understand me but i do identify as
korean
and i do look korean now i do feel
korean i don't identify as british so
[ __ ] what's your passport say exactly i
identify and that's just my culture
that's my home country
that's exactly how i look now um and i
also identified jimmy and that's my
career name but
uh not only that i just i know it's a
little bit confusing for some people
nobody's ever come out as jimmy or
korean but um
this is something that you guys know if
you follow my journey for the last eight
years i really struggled with identity
issues
with who i am you know with who i am
it's a very tough one so
i finally had the courage i've undergone
my um racial
uh i can't think of the words
transitional surgery you know i've
transitioned to a non-binary person
they them korean german and um i finally
have the korean look so i'm actually
really happy
no that's all
no one can acknowledge that you have a
hard time with your identity and
whatever like this
and also one can also acknowledge that
that still doesn't give you the right to
choose to be korean it's not a choice
this is something that's either
hereditary or gone through a citizenship
process
you can't just say i am korean therefore
i am that's not the way it works
sorry they should probably have a great
bit where he says listen you can
identify us whatever you want that's
fantastic but at what point do i have to
participate
in your unicorn world
and we don't we don't have to and that's
why everyone's looking at you side eye
so you can say you're korean you're
korean
and this is about me and this is what i
want for me but the truth is unless
other people accept you that label
literally means nothing
right understand that that umbrella term
for korean is something that's communal
basis something that ties people to a
space of land a shared history a shared
experience
share food customs culture right for you
to just come here and think you have an
entitlement to that because you say so
is absolutely absurd
and if you don't understand that ask
racial dolls out exactly
i've been very trapped in my body for so
long and you know i identified the
korean culture
i've lived in korea i speak the language
i have the korean look now i look
completely korean
if you didn't know who i was you would
just think i was a korean person no no
no no no no i came into this thinking
you looked confused
and i'm not yes just to confirm like a
dunk
it's just confirmed like a danking perm
yeah are you confused yeah
not a man or woman just a person um and
you know people might think i'm such a
joke but you know what guys you don't
understand if you're trapped in the
wrong body your whole life like you
don't understand um i haven't been
trapped in this body my whole life but
it's been the last eight years and it's
been very tough i've been very confused
and i've had so many people online
bullying me about my looks uh my love of
gym my love of career and people just
don't get it no one's done this before
but i just want to take the brave step
listen you not being comfortable and
cool with who you are something that a
lot of people can relate to
doesn't mean that you're trans racial no
most people grow up with some form of
like body dysmorphia or not comfortable
with how they look
or their nationality or their race okay
it's an issue that's relevant you're not
special
you're not someone who's dealing with a
struggle that nobody else can understand
so you know that's more arrogance and
narcissism that you start to see in
folks
i don't want to receive any backlash for
this because this is a very personal
thing to share you guys like
uh you know people online like youtubers
they would say oh he does things
retention like
nobody would do this for attention
nobody would go through this much pain
this much suffering i've had 18
surgeries in total for the last eight
years nobody would do that some
self-retention like i'm doing
people definitely do this for attention
100 people do all kinds of weird stuff
for attention
i mean people put out their own sex
tapes for attention okay
it's hard to it's hard to believe since
in your speech
you're making something you're making
yourself special out of something that
does not
like that's attention you want to feel
like you're special but this is not
this ain't this this this is not special
it's not
you should make it a big thing it's not
a thing so
just that yeah you want to be special
but it's it's not you're not special
i'm doing this because it's how i
identify it's how i feel so i just want
people to please be respectful in the
comments please be respectful online
spencer please be respectful online
that's not how the online world will
work
hey brother man welcome to the internet
you about to get a crash course baby
this man said please please and the
internet took that person
of course he went he went before james
brown on it
please please please
please no i just want to say some of my
fans uh
are in countries where it's not possible
to come out as non-binary or to to be
themselves and i just want to say
please have strength please have courage
one day your time will come you'll be
able to freely express yourself and uh
i will always try my best to give you
guys a voice give you guys a platform
and be a champion for the non-binary
community you can't call yourself a
champion
to call yourself a champion you gotta
win something you gotta win
races wait you calling yourself a
champion i'm gonna be the one with
who the hell yo
yo apparently jimin is like a korean
k-pop celebrity now he's jimin that's
one of his pronouns
i don't want to do this anymore
if we had this information before
let's see if he's done the work what
work
he speaks the language what does he
that's what he said
i don't know no uh let me let me hear
him let me see
all right
okay hello doctor
how are you doing
bro bro bro i watch too many korean
dramas to watch you butcher that [ __ ]
right like listen if i can pronounce it
better than you and i'm not even trying
ignore ollie london now and ollie london
is a man in his 30s he knows exactly
what he's doing because if i see ollie
london
[Music]
one more time
[Applause]
is
i recognized ollie london's face from
somewhere
and then it hit me so we have this
picture terrible photoshopping by the
way ollie
he looks like the cart but what's up
this straight roasting his ass
korean barbecue style he said he looked
like a titan [ __ ]
hello hello isaac great to be here
thanks for having me on the show no
thank you for reaching out to us i think
it's the first time we've ever gotten a
chance to actually
interview somebody who's reached out to
us first oh really
yeah oh she started that let's let's
hear this no i know we've seen it enough
yeah um ali
no there's an attention [ __ ] and uh you
know they wanted attention they got it
so it is this whole transracial movement
is stupid so it is at least rachel
jolie's all
was undercover and passed she did and
then you know what
oh my god she did black hair she did
black hair
london makes me appreciate rachel
dolezal crazy crazy
isn't it ollie london is to rachel
dolezal what steven crowder is to ben
shapiro for me
pretty much you know what i'm saying ben
should be wrong yeah seven crowd that
makes you appreciate better yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah y'all yeah so when i
see stuff like this
is incredibly cringe that's absolutely
nonsense my korean action is better than
yours it's crazy
we got a problem yeah i'm trying i'm not
even trying out of watching i watched
the korean
a couple korean dramas you know you know
the same one where you know the
guy dies from cancer and yeah he's never
happy i watched that like 12 years ago
pretty addicted for like two weeks and
then i stopped watching them and i
picked up a few words
crazy yeah and you got a better accent
yeah i'm gonna summon this
son
i already told you man this is how i
know it's korean if they sound like
they're complaining
it sounds korean
lazy complaining but yeah but anyways
no that's my thoughts that's just not
got anything uh yeah i'm still going to
go by
your majesty your imagination's not he
should we
it's uh your imagination
[Applause]
no just know [ __ ] outta here
[Music]
i'll be the one